♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
TOM FRIEDMAN HAS BEEN A
COLUMNIST AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOR 25
YEARS.
IN THAT QUARTER-CENTURY,
FRIEDMAN HAS RAISED BANALITY AND
CLICHE MONGERING TO A KIND OF
ART FORM, LIKE PICASSO, HE
WASTES NOTHING.
THERE’S NOT A SINGLE PIECE OF MY
LIST CONVENTIONAL WISDOM
FLOATING AROUND WASHINGTON OR
NEW YORK CITY THE TOM FRIEDMAN
HASN’T MANAGED TO WHIP INTO A
HASTY COLUMN AT ONE TIME OR
ANOTHER.
NATURALLY OUR RULING CLASS WOULD
LOVE TO SEE HIM, THEY READ TOM
FRIEDMAN ON THE PALATINE EVERY
MORNING AND FEEL AFFIRMED.
HE IS AS DUMB AS THEY ARE.
WE REFER YOU TO THE COLUMN THIS
MORNING BECAUSE THERE’S NO
QUESTION IT’S TASTE OF THINGS TO
COME AND VERY SOON.
IN THAT COLUMN, FRIEDMAN CALLS
FOR JOE BIDEN TO SKIP THE FALL
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
FOR COVER, FRIEDMAN ADDS A
COUPLE SILLY CAVEATS.
BIDEN SHOULD ONLY CONSIDER
DEBATING, HE WRITES, IF
DONALD TRUMP RELEASES YEARS OF
HIS PERSONAL TAX RETURNS AND
THEN AGREES TO HAVE A PANEL OF
JOURNALISTS SET ON STAGE TO CALL
HIM A LIAR IN REAL-TIME.
OTHERWISE, NO DEBATING.
TURNS OUT TOM FRIEDMAN IS NOT
REALLY A GENIUS WITH PRETTY
HABITS WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
THIS IS THE MOST CYNICAL
ELECTION STRATEGY EVER LYSED OR
EVER PERPETRATED ON AMERICAN
VOTERS.
HIDE THE CANDIDATES UNTIL
ELECTION DAY.
THE COUNTRY CAN FIND OUT WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION AFTER IT’S IN
POWER BUT UNTIL THEN NO
APPEARING IN PUBLIC AND
MY GOD, DON’T EVER TELL THE
TRUTH.
SO WHAT IF THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
WOULD TAKE TOM FRIEDMAN’S
ADVICE?
OF COURSE THEY WILL TAKE IT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
BIDEN IS UP IN THE POLLS WILL BE
CAN’T LET THEM TALK.
THAT COULD WRECK EVERYTHING.
PEOPLE MIGHT DISCOVER THAT
JOE BIDEN BEARS NO RESEMBLANCE
TO JOE BIDEN THEY REMEMBER.
>> THEY WOULD PUT 720 MILLION
BACK, MILLION WOMEN BACK IN THE
WORKFORCE.
I LOVE THIS PLACE.
WHAT’S NOT TO LIKE ABOUT VERMONT
IN TERMS OF THE BEAUTY OF IT AND
WHAT I NEED TOWN.
POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRIGHT AND
JUST AS TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
WE CHOOSE SCIENCE OVER FICTION.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
ALL MEN AND WOMEN CREATED BY
THAT -- YOU KNOW THE THING.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW THE THING.
IN FACT, WE DO KNOW THE THING,
BUT POOR JOE BIDEN DOES NOT KNOW
THE THING AND HE DOESN’T SEEM TO
KNOW ANYTHING OR EVEN RECOGNIZE
HIS OWN WAY.
IMAGINE BIDEN SPENDING SIX HOURS
ON STAGE WITH DONALD TRUMP
TRADING JABS ON LIVE TELEVISION.
OH, HE CAN’T DO THAT.
SO HE’S NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
INSTEAD THEY’RE GOING TO KEEP
JOE BIDEN HIDDEN BEHIND A
CURTAIN.
HE WILL READ A PREPARED SPEECH
FROM TIME TO TIME.
ON A GOOD DAY, HE CAN PULL THAT
OFF AND NOTHING EXTEMPORANEOUS
OR OFF-THE-CUFF.
HE’S NOT CAPABLE OF THAT.
IT’S ALL PRETTY SHOCKING IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
WE’VE KIND OF ACCEPTED ACCEPTED
ABOUT PULL BACK A LITTLE BIT.
THEY ARE RUNNING A CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT WHO CAN’T GOVERN AND T
DOING IT ANYWAY.
SO WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THAT
PEOPLE AROUND JOE BIDEN?
WELL, THEY ARE RUTHLESS
OBVIOUSLY, AND THEY ARE NOT INTO
DEBATE, NOT JUST PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE BUT ANY DEBATE.
THEY DON’T LIKE THEY DISAGREED
WITH.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO
SIDES TO ANY QUESTION.
THEY BELIEVE THEIR OWN VIEWS ARE
THE ONLY LEGITIMATE VIEWS.
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE THEM, THEY
WON’T ENGAGE WITH YOU.
THEY DON’T BOTHER TO REBUT YOUR
POINT.
BASICALLY TACKY.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF ATTACKED THE
SHOW TODAY, IN FACT.
HE DIDN’T RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE RAISE.
HE CALLED US NAMES.
AND THEN HIS MINIONS TRIED TO
PULL US OFF THE AIR.
WE SURVIVED BECAUSE THANK GOD WE
WORK HERE.
BUT YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT’S HOW
THEY PLAN TO RUN THE COUNTRY.
BIDEN WILL PICK SOME RUNNING
MATE WHOSE IDENTITY MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANYONE TO
CRITICIZE HER, AND THEN THEY
WILL DESCRIBE ANY CRITICISM OF
THEIR GOVERNMENTS AS A
HATE CRIME.
WE GOT A TASTE OF THAT.
YEARS UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
YOU KNOW HOW IT WORKS.
OF COURSE THEY DID AGAIN FOR
YEARS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
INCORPORATE DIVERSITY SEMINARS.
ANY PLACE WITH A TOTAL CONTROL.
NOW THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
POPULATION IS GETTING THE VERY
SAME TREATMENT.
TONIGHT CLOSE TO 1,000 COMPANIES
ARE BOYCOTTING FACEBOOK’S
ADVERTISING PLATFORM.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
BECAUSE THEY ARE DEMANDING THAT
FACEBOOK CENSOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS VOTERS.
BAN CONSERVATIVE NEWS OUTLETS,
ALLOW ONLY PUBLICATIONS
CONTROLLED BY THE LEFT TO DECIDE
WHAT’S NEWS.
LET’S MOST ANYWAY BECAUSE
THERE’S ONLY ONE MASS MEDIA COMP
THAT CONSISTENTLY DISSENTS FROM
THE LEFT’S VIEW OF THINGS.
YOU’RE WATCHING IT RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY PLAN TO
DO TO FOX NEWS IF THEY TAKE
POWER?
YOU CAN IMAGINE.
WE ARE IN THEIR WAY.
SO THESE PEOPLE AREN’T LIBERALS.
WE CALL THEM THAT BUT THEY ARE
NOT.
THEY DON’T WRING THEIR HANDS AND
WONDERING WHAT TO DO NEXT LIKE
YOUR FLAKY FIFTH-GRADE TEACHER
WHO WORE SANDALS AND WERE ABOUT
THE FEET OF THE BABY PARK SEALS
OR HAD A SAVE THE WHALE STICKER
ON HER VOLVO.
NO, THEY ARE NOTHING LIKE THAT.
THEY ARE NOT SENTIMENTAL.
THESE ARE TOTALITARIANS.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WANT.
THEY DON’T WRING THEIR HANDS.
THEY WANT POWER.
THEY KNOW HOW TO GET POWER.
WHY ARE SOME OF THE PEOPLE BEING
FIRE RIGHT NOW?
FOR ABSURDLY TRIVIAL OFFENSES,
LIKING THE WRONG TWEET,
COMMENTING ON THE ROTTEN TOAST,
MAKING THE WRONG HAND GESTURE
ACCIDENTALLY.
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
SIMPLE.
TO TERRIFY THE REST OF US INTO
OBEDIENCE.
WE BETTER NOT SAY THAT.
WE COULD BE HURT TOO.
THAT’S LOVE LESSON WE TAKE AS WE
WATCH PEOPLE AROUND US FIRED AND
DESTROYED FOR DOING VERY SMALL
THINGS.
THAT TELLS US THE PEOPLE AROUND
JOE BIDEN, THEY’RE THE ONES
DOING THIS, RULED BY FEAR.
THEY DO NOT RULE BY CONSENT, AS
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE IN FACT THE TRUE
ENEMIES OF DEMOCRACY.
THEY DON’T CARE WHAT YOU THINK.
I’M JUST IN CASE THE REST OF US
MISSED THE POINT, THEY’RE
WORKING HARD TO MAKE
SELF-DEFENSE AGAINST THEIR MOBS,
THEIR MILITIA, A CRIME.
YOU CANNOT RESIST US OR WE WILL
PROSECUTE YOU.
ST. LOUIS CIRCUIT ATTORNEY KIM
GARDNER IS THREATENING TO ARREST
MARK AND PATRICIA MCCLOSKEY FOR
DARING TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST A MOB THAT WAS
THREATENING TO MURDER THEM.
A BOB OF DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
A THEY ARE THE CRIMINAL.
THIS IS WHY THE LEFT WANTS TO
ABOLISH THE POLICE.
THEY ARE NOT ABOLISHING
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE REPLACING THEM WITH A
WOKE MILITIA OF ARMED SOCIAL
WORKERS, PSYCHOLOGIST, AND
ETHNIC STUDIES MAJORS.
A OBEDIENT DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
AND IT’S WHY IN PLACES WHERE THE
POLICE STILL EXIST, THEY WANT TO
MAKE CERTAIN YOU ARE TOO AFRAID
TO CALL THEM.
IN SAN FRANCISCO, SUPERVISOR
INTRODUCED THE CAUTION AGAINST
RACIALLY EXPERT TATE OF
NONEMERGENCIES OR KAREN ACT.
HILARIOUS IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
ALLOW WE ARE TOLD IS AGAINST
HATE THAT IS NAMED AFTER A
RACIAL SLUR.
BUT IT’S NOT ACTUALLY THAT
FUNNY.
THE BILL WOULD MAKE IT A
HATE CRIME FOR CITIZENS TO CALL
ON ENFORCEMENT BASED ON "RACIAL
BIAS."
HOW EXACTLY DO YOU THINK THAT
LAW WILL BE APPLIED?
YOU DON’T HAVE TO WONDER.
CALL THE POLICE BECAUSE YOU’RE
FRIGHTENED OF MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS THREATENING TO KILL
YOU?
YOU ARE THE CRIMINAL NOW.
AND DAY BY DAY, LIBERALISM
EVAPORATES AND THE LEFT’S TROOPS
WHO CALL THEMSELVES LIBERALS,
CHILDREN OF THE ENLIGHTENMENT,
ARE FALLING IN LINE BEHIND WHAT
IS CLEARLY A POWER GRAB.
JUST TODAY, THE FOUNDER OF
VOX.COM, EZRA KLEIN, SOMEONE
REGARDED AS AN INTELLECTUAL
ON THE LEFT, WENT ON TWITTER TO
EXPLAIN WHY FREE-SPEECH IS
ACTUALLY VERY BAD.
"A LOT OF DEBATE THAT SELL
THEMSELVES ABOUT BEING ABOUT
FREE SPEECH ARE ACTUALLY
ABOUT POWER AND THERE’S A LOT
OF POWER IN BEING ABLE TO CLAIM
AND HOLD THE MANTLE OF
FREE-SPEECH DEFENDER."
OH, WE SEE WHERE YOU’RE GOING.
ACTUALLY EZRA KLEIN IS HALF
RIGHT.
FREE-SPEECH DEFINITELY IS ABOUT
POWER.
POWER FOR PEOPLE WHO DON’T HAVE
ANY.
PEOPLE LIKE EZRA KLEIN WANT LESS
FREE-SPEECH FOR OTHERS SO THEY
CAN HAVE MORE POWER.
WHEN THEY CAN TELL YOU WHAT YOU
CAN SAY, WHAT THEY ARE REALLY
TELLING YOU IS WHAT YOU’RE
ALLOWED TO BELIEVE.
THEY ARE NOT CONTROLLING YOUR
MOUTH.
THEY ARE CONTROLLING YOUR MIND.
AND THERE IS NO DEEPER CONTROL
THAN THAT.